and since I know but I want to give you
all can I give you a compliment
sure all right so throughout your career
though you've had a resilient career and
don't get me wrong he's a nice guy who
Scott start out strong yeah
stick to what we know Ryan I rise
because I've worked with Scott oh so I
wanted to tell you the thing with the
doors like the doors yeah because people
are waiting to you what happened so I
used to do this thing where alright so
we're doing a scene with with my real
sons in the show where we're gonna go
dump garbage it's the one thing they
like used from me because God forbid
they go through my tapes like this one
producer I don't want to say his name
but he actually produced Roseanne and uh
the original Roseanne right and he goes
I don't know what's wrong with the guys
you're working with you know Allen
Stevens he gave me my first acting joke
a yeah so he goes if I was producing
dice the TV show he goes the first thing
I would say is why don't you just bore
me to tears with the tapes you you keep
talking about with the episodic tapes
that you just bore me for three days
show me your tapes yeah you know because
if you watch those tapes you got episode
if the episode if the episode yeah of a
berserk comics life yeah you know I know
I'm nuts I'm not nuts like but those nut
house you know I could still use because
Ari Shaffir and I was very sick I know
that and you signed it yeah I'm on it
you mean ari Stephen is Izzy Sebastian
Bastian everybody everyone's in it yeah
yeah but we were young but think of the
fight with you or not we'll get into
that in a minute but that's what I'm
saying I wanted violence in the show
they wouldn't even get me to violence I
wanted you know on dice you know it's
Scott this [ __ ] yo-yo
you know and I know he did old school
good yeah I created rock and roll comedy
you understand yeah I did the Rose Bowl
he's gonna tell me what I need to do on
film yeah is the reason people showed up
that's why I was talking about the
internet you forgot that part when I
said no Twitter no Facebook cause of
these reasons people are aerosols
they're older they never went anywhere
and they just [ __ ] bitter and then so
I stuck with Instagram because at least
with Instagram it's creative right you
know what I mean people get creative
yeah you know except most of the women
with their sayings don't let it define
you shut the [ __ ] up Dear Abby you know
what I mean don't let him defy trust the
[ __ ] process what process you open my
legs you know can I do my balls dear
fatty nice sweet girlfriend yeah what do
you think we was doing all night why do
you think I had to come here later I
know I care about those details I just I
just give you a [ __ ] compliment how
beautiful she is
I don't care about if you smashed or
grabbed her little key why are you
talking about her like that your
girlfriend I call it sugar plum see when
a guy says something like let's say a
girl gets out of a car
you know it's dressed a certain way oh I
like those pants you're wearing I've had
this fight by the way yeah and and I'll
say to the guy like what what does that
mean
what is it what do you think it means I
like the pants no no but I know because
I'm from Brooklyn what that means what
does that mean you don't know because
the way you're from say no but I'm just
saying we mean if a guy complimented on
you on your pants
no on a girl then on a girls piss yeah
oh I like those pants yeah why what was
it your business why does she need to
know how you like a pants that's the
guy's way of getting away with saying
I'd like to [ __ ] you okay I have friends
for years beautiful girlfriend you got a
beautiful girlfriend I'm not gonna
comment on anything about her it's not
my business compliment so you're right
you know I have a lot of girlfriends who
like it but when when when apart when
they're not being complimented on their
looks but an object that they're wearing
and I always tell him that's actually
[ __ ] he's telling you he's coming on
to you he's just being subtle about and
being roundabout about it and he's
coming on right in front of the guy yeah
I know exactly you're absolutely right
but I don't stand for that so you stop
it yeah you stop it yeah no they make
like I don't know you thought no you
know exactly what I'm doing like I would
say to this guy go they ever come
compliment your your wife yeah on
anything she's wearing or an outfit no
because then it's me getting away with
saying hey I won't mind getting a piece
of this oh yeah see I don't buy that
Schiff I saw you with your girlfriend
yeah
don't even look at her anybody really
looking at up for long like you see how
notice if you watch the tapes back look
at her watch the tapes back yeah
I'm basically like I'll give her a
glance but I'm basically focused on Rai
what if i sat here like this Bobby
you know what I think weird no it's good
yes you know I know that if you know the
difference a Brooklyn it's from Brooklyn
that's right
sorry to interrupt but we have my
favorite sponsor we want to share with
you no speech posts if you're hungry and
you don't want to drive anywhere postman
post mates is your personal food
delivery grocery delivery whatever kind
of delivery service all year round
anything you're craving posts mates can
deliver they're the largest on-demand
network in the US and offer delivery
from all the restaurants grocery and
convenience stores and traditional
retailers you can possibly want to me or
need 24 hours a day 365 days post mates
will bring you what you need I'm reading
it within the hour don't do that again
no more you don't even know where the
store is
post mates anything for anything I told
you I was doing it download the app for
iOS or Android for free browse local
restaurants and businesses finish it
Go Go babe finish your sentence and
track your delivery in real time for a
limited time post mates giving our
listeners $100 as a free delivery credit
for your first 7 days so start your free
deliveries download the app and use the
code belly that's the code belly for
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days when you download the post
mates app anything you need anytime you
need it
post mated download post mates and save
with the code belly enjoy the rest of
the show better net group the white male
is an [ __ ]
exactly just telling ya what I come
across all the time yeah you know when I
meet fans that are aren't white guys
yeah the most respectful nicest you know
they're not in your face with a [ __ ]
camera you know grabbing you're going on
this came out blurry so I
yeah you know I mean yeah they're just
disrespectful that's that's what it's
come down to it is so funny because when
we used to at the store before cell
phones and digital camera yes that's
great you're gonna love this so we would
people would have disposable cameras
right the things that you would just go
to Kodak and get them all right and so
whenever they would ask dyes for photo
he would have one of us take the photo
but we knew the rule they knew the
routine we knew the routine you always
cut dices head out of you had to angle
it down all right Bobby take the baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it would go
are you are you getting the picture like
why wouldn't you be getting the picture
getting my shoulder yeah you know but
I'm never I would love to see so many of
those picture was that what and I always
laughed well not of them
how many beautiful moons and stuff I
know but imagine you know going back to
Michigan right and you're going to the
Kodak Store and you get the pictures
back and none of them I loved when the
new generation a comics came in which
was Barbie and Rena ZZ and did Ari ever
go anywhere yeah he's big now other than
the ghosts killing it